you would never drop a new engineer into a Rails app and say, just figure it out.
I spent a lot of my career being responsible for getting engineers productive inside of
real production code bases, and the pattern is pretty consistent. The faster they understand the
setup, the architecture, the product context, the tests, and the decisions behind the code,
the faster they can make good changes. If we haven't met yet, I'm Damian,
and I've been a software engineer for over 15 years. Today, I want to show you how I set up a
repo so that a coding agent has the context it needs before it starts changing code.
Because the usual workflow is almost the opposite.
We open the repo, paste in the task, and expect the agent to infer the setup commands,
the architecture, and the product context, and the testing expectations from the code alone.
So I'm going to walk you through how I set up agent onboarding inside of a real repo.
Let's take a look.
This is CreatorSignal.
It's a Ruby on Rails app that I've been building for a little while now.
You might have seen me working on it in some of my live streams in the past.
And so I'm going to walk you through how I set up onboarding for the agent inside of this repo.
The first thing we're going to look at is the AGENTS.md file.
This is the root of everything.
And so AGENTS.md is going to be used by various coding agents, including Codex and others.
Now, I've also symlinked this file to the CLAUDE.md, so that way they're referencing the same file.
And in here, we give the agent a description of the Rails app itself,
so giving it some context on the application and how to orient itself inside of our application.
The first piece is we talk about the project.
So we talk about how CreatorSignal is an AI content strategist for YouTube creators.
Users submit the idea.
The app researches it across YouTube, Reddit, X, and Hacker News,
and then returns a scored go, refine, kill verdict with evidence and recommendations.
So we give it this kind of like baseline understanding of what the application is
so it knows what it's working inside of.
Then we also mentioned that CreatorSignal is a Rails 8.1 app
built with Thoughtbot Suspenders, PostgreSQL with pgvector, SolidQueue, and Hotwire.
The next kind of important part of this is we give it some instructions on how to build
and run the app.
So in this case, we walk through the various commands that are there.
So bin/setup for installing dependencies and preparing the app, bin/setup --reset so it can
reset the local state and reseed, bin/dev which is going to start a dev server and local processes,
and then bin/jobs which starts the SolidQueue worker on its own when it's not running inside of
Puma.
Now the agent knows how to kind of get things started whenever it needs to.
Now onto the session startup.
This is one of the more important pieces of the AGENTS.md setup that I have going.
In here I basically explain to the agent what it should do whenever we start a new session
so that it can kind of catch itself up on what we've been working on and where it is.
So it's broken up into about seven steps here.
And the first is going to ask it to run the PWD.
So here we're just confirming that you are in the right repo so it knows where it is
inside of the system. The next we do a git status with the short and branch flags. So this just
kind of gives it information on what branch it's on and the current status of the local changes. So
whether the work tree might be dirty or not. Then we have it run git log with one line and get
basically the last 10 logs. So this kind of gives it an opportunity to catch itself up on what kind
of work has been happening in the past before it got here. And we go ahead and run git fetch origin
because sometimes I run into issues where maybe various changes have been pushed up to the remote
and Codex doesn't automatically remember to maybe pull down those changes.
So here it's going to actually run fetch origin.
It doesn't actually pull the changes down,
but it gives itself some context to know that what is up against origin main.
You might, if you want, in your setup, you might want to say get fetch origin
and then have it maybe run get rebase origin main or pull or something like that.
Then we have it read a progress MD.
So you may or may not have this kind of file,
But sometimes a progress.md is used for kind of keeping track of progress inside of the application.
This can be useful also for like long running sessions.
So maybe you're running, you're working on say one larger epic and you want to be able to keep track of the progress of that epic inside of this progress.md file.
So that way if you need to say clear context window or anything like that, it can go ahead and kind of refresh from the progress.md to catch itself up and bring itself back up to speed.
The next is to read the relevant docs.
So there's a docs folder, which has different documentation,
and then there's a map further below that we'll kind of get to.
And then we run a targeted smoke check.
So making sure that the repo is in a clean state
and that things are working and operational.
So if the repo is already failing for some reason,
say whether that's test or linting errors or formatting
or anything like that, we're going
to have the agent report those things back to us
so we know, so that we can decide what to do about it,
so that we're not just working inside of, say, a broken state
from the start.
So then we go into our test commands.
Here we outline the various ways to run the test suite.
So for instance, we have bin rail spec.
That's how you run the full test suite.
We have bundle exec rspec with a path.
That's how you run a single individual test.
Then we have how to run it by a single individual test on a specific case.
How we run linting, how we can do a security scan,
how to check for vulnerabilities in our dependencies,
and then bin CI, which is the full CI, lint, and security tests.
So kind of how you can run everything.
Online 40, we give it some instructions on what it should do while it's iterating.
So typically, when it's running through its feature, it should use targeted specs while it's iterating.
So basically running the individual tests for maybe the files that are impacted by its changes
or the surrounding tests and things like that.
But then later, it should run the relevant broader spec before finishing.
the architecture docs. So we have a section in the docs around architecture, which goes into a code
map, domain model, service boundaries, and architectural patterns. We highlight some key
facts such as Rails models represent users, ideas, validations. The research orchestration
lives in app services. There's some background validation work that runs through SolidQueue,
and the UI behavior uses Hotwire, and there's multiple databases set up. The docs architecture
will go into more deeper contents about this
so it can kind of catch itself up from there.
Then we reach the documentation map.
Here's where we kind of outline
where the various pieces of documentation might live
so that it knows where to find things.
So we also instructed to read the relevant doc
before starting work in an area.
So some examples of those are,
there's the documentation index, which is in docs/README.md.
There are stack patterns and domain model.
That's in docs/ARCHITECTURE.md.
We have testing patterns and stack,
and that's in docs/TESTING.md.
credentials, env vars, API keys, that's in docs/CONFIGURATION.md, so how we configure the application,
and the list kind of goes on from here. So mapping the directions or where to find any documentation
that the agent might want to have. So for things like this, like an agent might find it on its own,
but it might have to go searching more and more, so it might use your tokens to use those steps.
Here we give it that straight map so it knows exactly where to look, instead of having it to
spend tokens to kind of find where all of these documentations live. So it's both a guide for
helping the agent be successful in the code base, but also a tool to help you kind of save some
tokens. Next, we go into our definition of done. This is important to guide the agent so it
understands when it should consider its work complete. This prevents those scenarios where
the agent says, I'm done, but it actually hasn't finished all the work. So now let's dive into the
actual docs themselves and what the agent would see. So this is the docs readme file, which kind
gives just an index of what exists in this folder.
We've stored some product specs, which explain
how the product is meant to function
from a product design perspective,
including the core index, an API and CLI spec,
and some archive ideas.
We provide some notes for references.
We have some Stripe webhooks infrastructure that's set up,
and so there's an entire section dedicated to that.
Then we have design documents, so core beliefs
around how we design the application,
so engineering principles and invariants for the code base.
Design docs is for design explorations and non-ADR engineering notes.
ADRs are architecture decision records.
We use those to capture significant decisions and their rationale behind them.
So this allows the agent to kind of understand the changes that have been made over time
and why we made those decisions.
That is useful for when sometimes you go back and forth with an agent,
build something out, come back later, and the agent kind of decides,
well, I'm going to do something differently.
Here, it can kind of look through the ADRs
and understand how we got to those points
and why the rationale was there
and kind of use that to guide it
as it moves forward through new decisions.
We have the first,
which is the agent-ready documentation structure.
The second one is the Rails Hotwire Monolith Baseline.
Then we have decision-oriented validation reports,
pluggable research agent tools,
async validation lifecycle,
and idempotent webhook event storage.
Now let's take a look at ARCHITECTURE.md.
Here we start off with the stack.
So understanding the core technology
that powers the application and the system.
So we talk about Rails, it's on Rails 8.1.
The database is using PostgreSQL with pgvector.
Background jobs use SolidQueue.
Frontend is Hotwire and Turbo and Stimulus.
For JavaScript, we have an import map,
so no Node.js build step.
Our assets are handled by Propshaft
and some details about the Docker DB image.
Domain model covers some of the core concepts
side of the system. CreatorSignal validates YouTube video ideas, and the core flow is a user
submits a video idea. A validation job is enqueued. The research agent runs tools against YouTube,
Reddit, X, and Hacker News. Results are synthesized into a scored, go, refined, kill verdict,
and the report is displayed with evidence and recommendations. Key Models. We talk about the
key models that exist inside the application. So we have User. So that includes the authentication
and subscription plan. Idea is a video idea submitted for validation. Validation is one run
of the research agent against an idea. Stripe webhook event, idempotent store for all incoming
Stripe events. And a channel is a user's YouTube channel injected into the research context.
Then we outline some of the core services that we have. So we note that the research agent is the
orchestrates the research loop. We have tools. So for base, registry, YouTube search, comments,
YouTube channel stats, ExaSearch, and XSearch. Then we go into the project structure, so app
components for view components, controllers, which is a typical MVC controllers folder,
jobs for active job, mailers, models, services, views, etc. Then we outline the spec directory. So
the spec has factories, models, services, and system. And we outline that factories use factory
bot and that the system specs are capybar system tests. Then we go into some key patterns in the
application. So we have strict loading. N plus one queries are caught automatically. Use strict
loading false only when it's intentional and documented. We use strong migrations. So strong
migrations are used for validating for safety and that it should only use safety assured only after
verifying the migration is safe. So this is helpful for making sure that an agent is making migrations
responsibly as it's building them out. Now let's take a look at some of our product specs. We won't
go too deeply into the first one, but you can see here that this outlines basically the core concept
of what CreatorSignal is as a whole. We talk about the feature index. So there's the idea
submission flow, the research agent, the validation report, the gated shared reports. And we've also
noted what has been shipped and what hasn't been. So right now, all of those features in the feature
index have been shipped. If we dive into the CreatorSignal API and CLI, we can see that this was a
future feature that I started creating afterwards, after the core kind of MVP of the project was
And so here we were trying to create an API for agents to use using an agent skill or an MCP to actually interface with CreatorSignal.
And so this was a product spec that we built out together with an agent and then broke up into actual implementation.
So we have the overview.
It's currently a web only product and we want to move it to a CLI driven batch validation.
PRD defines a JSON API that enables AI agents to submit ideas and retrieve results programmatically.
CLI tools to validate ideas from the terminal without opening the browser.
And a webhook for consumers to react to validation completions in real time.
We established some goals, some non-goals, and then some overview of what we're trying to build.
So including a data model, what the authentication flow was going to look like, the key management, rate limiting, and API endpoints.
So here we kind of defined everything we were trying to work towards when building out this application and building out this feature set.
So a lot of effort was put into kind of planning out what the feature was going to look like before we actually dove into passing it off to the agent to implement.
So now let's look into the decisions folder, which holds our ADRs.
This is an example of one such ADR.
So number six was idempotent webhook event storage.
So here we end up capturing the pattern we used for handling Stripe webhooks.
So CreatorSignal receives Stripe webhooks for billing state and sends validation webhooks
for external consumers.
Webhooks are inherently retry prone.
So providers can send duplicates, jobs can fail midway, and operators need to inspect
and replay events when production behavior is unclear.
And so what we did was we made a decision
to store all the incoming webhook events before processing.
So the Stripe controller verifies and constructs the event,
then creates or finds a Stripe webhook event by Stripe event ID.
And the whole payload is then stored into the database
so that if we need to replay it, retry it, or anything like that, we can.
It also gives us that ability to kind of replay or rebuild the structure
if that ever happens.
This ADR captures all the decisions that we made
when we were building out this specific feature
and how we got there.
And then we actually also link out to different sources,
like say the docs references Stripe webhooks,
what models were involved and things like that.
So if we ever need to understand
how we got to a position,
we can go through these historical ADRs and understand that.
So now let's go ahead and actually run through a fix
in the system so that we can see all of this come into play.
So what we're gonna do is take a look at a feature
implemented a little bit incorrectly. So we have a feature for the API where the PRD
specifically calls out that every successful API key authentication should update the last_used_at,
but only once per minute to avoid write amplification.
And that's not happening right now. So I'm gonna go ahead and submit that prompt to Codex and let's
take a look at what it does as it kind of gets itself up to speed and works on this feature.
So we can see here the first thing it says, I'm going to follow the repo startup checklist first.
Then read the API CLI product spec and the current API key auth path before changing anything.
After that, I'll add the failing spec for the debounce behavior and make the smallest code change that satisfies it.
So we can see here already it's following our TDD practices that are defined in the AGENTS.md.
So it ran pwd, understanding where it is in the system.
It got the git status using short branch flags.
It did git log to understand what's been working on.
And it's doing a search for all the things related to the API key, debounce, and things like that.
Now it's saying the startup context.
So the repo is ahead of main by four commits, but there's no dirty changes locally.
And it's refreshing the remotes now and reading the API spec to understand what's there before it actually goes and touches anything.
Now it says it's confirming that the source of truth PRD explicitly calls that the debounce should be once per minute and that it doesn't currently do that.
It actually touches it every single time.
So now it's going to check the model and API controller specs to pin the right test layer.
So it's understanding where the right place to put this test is.
And it mentions that the mismatch is in the model and that the authenticate method currently owns both the verification and the last_used_at updates.
It's running the targeted model spec as the baseline smoke check, which is one of the things that we outlined as the session startup.
So it ran into a couple issues with Ruby using the system Ruby and not the one by mise.
So it's fixed that and ran the smoke test and everything's good.
So now that the baseline is clean, it's going to go ahead and actually add the test to recreate this issue and an expected failure.
So it ran that, but it caught an issue in the new spec before running it.
So re-authenticating just to read the timestamp with itself, exercise behavior,
tightening the spec to read via reload, so only writes are intentional auth calls.
So now that it has the debound spec in place, it's now going to run it.
And it has the first red test exposed a test helper gap, so it's fixing that.
So it refactored the code, implemented a fix.
And so now it says the model now exposes touch_last_used_at_if_stale,
and only writes when last_used_at is absent
or at least one minute old.
Now it's gonna rerun the focus spec.
Then it says it's gonna lint on the touched files
and if that stays green.
Now, once it's done that,
the focus model spec is green with the new debounce coverage.
I'm running the API auth request spec plus RuboCop next.
So now it's going one layer out to make sure
that the adjacent tests or more exposed tests
are running and passing as well.
Finally, it says that both the API auth request spec and RuboCop on the touched files pass,
so now it's going to do a final diff and status review now.
Given the narrow model change, I'll decide whether a broader suite run is worth the time after checking the footprint.
So, it's kind of determined based off the changes, the diff is limited to the API key model and its spec.
I'm running the full RuboCop command from AGENTS.md, but it's going to keep the test run targeted
because the affected behavior is isolated to the API key authentication.
So it's made a judgment call on its own that the full test suite likely doesn't
need to be run, but instead anything related to the API should.
So it's going to run those tests on its own instead.
And finally, it gives us a summarization of what was implemented and what was
changed along the way.
So we can see here how that kind of that whole system came into play.
It ran through lots of the pieces of the agent-ready docs,
including AGENTS.md, the product spec,
some of ARCHITECTURE.md and other files
to help it understand the code base
and the procedures that it should follow
whenever it was implementing this feature.
I like this example because the fix was small.
We didn't need a dramatic feature build to see the pattern.
Codex had a better shot at making the right change
because the repo gave it the same things
I would give a new engineer.
Some setup notes, architecture context, product context,
testing expectations and decisions behind the code.
This is what I mean by making a repo agent ready.
It's not about writing a giant prompt.
It's about moving the context out of your head
and into the code base where the agent can actually use it.
So before you ask an agent to make any serious changes,
ask yourself, if this were a new engineer
joining the project today,
what would I need to hand them first?
The answer is probably the same context
your coding agent needs.
If you want help getting your repo set up like this,
I've put together a free agent skill that you can use.
I'll leave a link in the description.
I'll see you in the next one.